president Trump's first face-to-face
meeting with Chinese President Xi
Jinping was overshadowed by the US
missile strikes in Syria but on Friday
at mar-a-lago the two leaders discussed
another global hotspot North Korea the
two-day summit ended Friday with the US
and China agreeing to increase
cooperation on pushing the North to
abandon its nuclear program north Korea
has stepped up testing of its ballistic
missiles in the past month and the trump
administration has indicated it could
take military action to counter that
threat for more on this were joined by
Jamie metzel a senior fellow for
technology and national security at the
Atlantic Council Jamie welcome to what
degree do you think that strikes on
Syria were in some ways a message a
warning sign to North Korea well they
were they were in a very significant way
president Trump many people have said
has been all talk and no action and this
attack certainly changes that and to
launch these strikes while president she
was with president Trump in Marla go
that's that's very very strong strong
statement at the same time the situation
in Syria and North Korea are very
different and it's one thing to launch
strikes it's another thing to have a
comprehensive strategy that can really
move the needle on North Korea so China
has been North Korea's biggest backer
for a long time do you expect meaningful
change in that relationship no because
China Seas North Korea not in and of
itself but through the prism of its
strategic rivalry with the United States
and unless China can see a change in
that relationship it's going to see
North Korea as a strategic asset and so
there's almost nothing North Korea can
do that will make China Sea North Korea
as a greater threat than a reunified
Korean Peninsula potentially elide to
the United States the other big topic at
the summit was trade president Trump has
been very aggressive in criticizing
China on trade was there any progress
made down there do we think it's too
early to tell there was an announcement
of a hundred day plan a plan to make a
plan for improved relations over the
next hundred days and we'll see if that
yields anything there wasn't any
announcement of any meaningful progress
on trade on South China Sea on on North
Korea but maybe the
is the beginning of an improved
relationship but it's too early to trump
said it was outstanding relation well
everything is outstanding for him the
question is is there a strategy to
change the situation with all of these
issues and right now yes it's easy to
have a press conference it's easy to
tweet it's even easy to shoot missiles
but to have a comprehensive strategy
that's going to change real things in
the world that's actually hard and we
haven't seen that I wonder how
disconcerted the Chinese are about this
president's bluster on trade thus far
because president Trump's withdrawal
from the trans-pacific partnership has
greatly benefited the Chinese Li you
must actually be sort of happy with
where things are at right the Chinese
are thrilled because right there was
certainly a level of nervousness with
President Trump coming in and all the
tough talk and then there's really been
no meaningful action to date and not
only that a president Trump has removed
as you correctly say I t's removed the
leverage that we've spent a decade
building and so from a Chinese
perspective the United States has is
coming from a much weaker position China
has been massively strengthened and yes
we can fire some missiles but the
question is is there a strategy and
president Trump doesn't even have a
foreign policy team so how could you
have a real strategy without the people
to develop that strategy well the
president has accepted the Chinese
president's invitation to visit we'll
see what happens when he goes could be
interesting maybe mental thank you very
much